Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and
Common question that we've received is can I get a protocol for my cancer?
What am I supposed to do? I mean we if you come come on born with us through our clinic and you become a full patient
We get a cheek swab from patients
We do testing pray over it and come up with a very specific protocol. Of course we can't do that for everybody on
this course, but we still want to take care of the masses. I really believe that's my calling. So we're trying to you know
when I get the book out and and give that away for free and we we have this course for a very inexpensive price and we have
people be able to communicate with us
every way we possibly can without just burying ourselves out but also giving you the best care possible.
This is why I created this section of the course
dealing with protocols. So honest answer can I give a protocol for my cancer? No, but
because we can't give medical advice to people who aren't true patients of ours, but we can make suggestions.
So in this section that you'll see here, there's some very you know specific
protocols that are common sense protocols for people with these types of cancer. Now we have to say that you need to
go back and talk to your practitioner, your oncologist, whoever you're dealing with because we don't treat cancer
or we're not treating disease and we certainly are not diagnosing. But we're making suggestions
and this whole course is an educational process for you. But here's some suggestions that you can you know
you're you're an adult and you can make your own healthcare decision. So you don't have to go back to
your doctor, but legally I have to tell you to do so. So understand where our scope is.
Personally we use nutrition, diet, emotional, spiritual support, prayer support and frequencies with
the right machine to help get your body to heal as best as we can. But it's your body that does
the healing. And that's really our perspective. We believe that you do the healing. It's not some
outside doctor that's that's got an answer for you. It's that your body is doing the healing. So we want
you to pray about these these general suggestions and really consider it. Take all this information in.
I'm sure you're getting information from other sources as well. Then you got to balance it out
because I do believe there's value in a multitude of counselors that you can balance this out.
Pray about it and come up with the best protocol for you.
Understand we can't give medical advice. I can't give medical advice on your medication.
Please don't ask me whether you should keep taking a steroid. Please don't ask
whether you should do kibble or not. I have videos on that that can help you work through that
decision yourself. But I can't tell you what to do. So we can't be put in that position. And you know
we already have the board that hates our guts. So we are available. We're going to try to be having
Zoom calls even on this course so that we can work through ideas with you. We can pray with you.
We can just be supporting you every possible way possible. That is our desire. So take these
protocols in this next section. Pray over them. Make your best decision possible. Bring it to
another practitioner if you need. Make the best decision that's going to be right for you.
And that's what we want. I mean ultimately we want you to have success through the information that
we can share with you as well. Thanks.